نتوقف الان مع ابطال صباح العربيه هم
المراسلون عبر العالم
[موسيقى]
لصباح العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن من لندن
مدينه العقبه احلام العبدلي تونس سمر
مشاتل صباح العربيه من المنوفيه رافض
غصيان من امام مسرح امريكان
برام الله خالد القاسم لصباح العربيه ندى
حجازي كفر الشيخ
[موسيقى]
روح للخرطوم صباح العربيه الريان الظاهر
وهالي صفيان ينورونا اهلا اهلا يا احلى
صباح معكم الريان وهاني من الرياض ينضم
الينا مراسل اسامه القاسم اسامه يسعد
صباحك اهلا بكم مباريات حاتمه اليوم كيف
تبدو الاجواء اليوم السعوديه بالاضافه
حكون معاكم اليوم من قلب المطبخ اليمني
عبد القادر العصيمي الرياض
الزي الذي كان من خلاله المقاتلين في
الدوله السعوديه جاعله منصات التواصل
والمواقع الاعلاميه وصناعها في طريقنا
للبتراويه واحده من اهم المناطق الاثريه
والسياحيه في القاره السمراء ما خطر في
بال الانسان القديم حين برق المذنب الاخضر
سند ابراهيم مواطن باريس
صباح العربيه اسماء انواع الخبز فهي
الاصعب نطقا حتى في اللغه الالمانيه من
جنوب المانيا ايهم القاسم صباح العربي
[موسيقى]